voting among other things it's the only
way to get Sean Spicer off Dancing with
the Stars
Samba he's danced the red wedding the
Woody from Toy Story after his third
divorce and this
[Music]
cool he is dressed and dancing there
like the Chernobyl musketeer
please America put this man out of
everyone's misery but now actually seems
like it might be a good time to talk
about voting because Election Day is
this Tuesday yes there are elections
this chubster depending on where you
live you could be voting for your
governor your state legislature or even
your city comptroller which is a very
important position they control the city
without them the city would be
completely out of control but but before
you vote which you absolutely should it
may be worth asking how much do you
trust the system that counts your
balance because the truth is many of us
don't know the first thing about how our
votes get counted when you cast your
ballot how do you know that they're
getting it right that they're getting it
right yeah oh well isn't that their job
do you trust that your vote is being
recorded as intended what do you think I
think so
what are you basing that on how do you
know that they got it right well I'm
sure they do but how do you know they're
getting it right I can't be like there's
no such thing as being dead sure well I
think I'm quite sure I honestly get the
point the interviewer is trying to make
but he is coming on pretty strong there
how are you so sure they got your vote
right is it cuz you're a stupid child in
a dumb adults body this gives you a born
yesterday in a voting booth and the
first thing you did was vote like a
newborn idiot before you go to bed do
you put a tooth out with pliers place
there's still bloody tooth underneath
your pillow and then lie there waiting
for the Tooth Fairy to suck you off do
you do that did lose sleep waiting for
tooth fairy then how do you
know they don't you vote right
but look please his overall point there
is decent we don't always know how our
votes are being counted and it's not
unreasonable to have some questions
about our election security we now know
that in 2016 Russian hackers targeted
election systems in all 50 states now
what they were targeting back then was
voter registration data as for the
voting machines themselves to hear some
local officials tell it they just could
not be more secure I could set one of
these machines in the middle of Red
Square in Moscow and the Russians
couldn't hack into it well don't do that
because of course they can hack into it
they're Russians there are precisely
three things that they are good at
hacking hockey and writing books so sad
they make you want to drink a potato but
as you're six tonight
as you see tonight leaving our voting
machines in the middle of Moscow or
indeed the middle of America might not
be the best idea because a Senate report
found that some of our voting equipment
is aging and vulnerable to exploitation
by a committed adversary so tonight
let's talk about our voting machines and
first you should know there is no single
standard voting system in this country
in some places are you vote by filling
out a paper ballot and feeding it into a
machine and others you press a button
get a printout and then have that
scanned into a different machine and
it's still others you press a
touchscreen and that's it that's the
whole voting process and what that last
option may seem like the best it's
actually for reasons that we'll get into
later the absolute worst now the reason
that most of us vote on electronic
machines at all has to do with the 2000
election and for those of you too young
to remember that first I've got to ask
you is euphoria accurate are you all
corny sparkly drug addicts I'm honestly
curious I don't know any teens and I
suspect the people behind you thoria
don't either
but but second very basically the 2000
election came down to just over a
thousand votes in Florida which
triggered a recount which turned out to
be an absolute nightmare because
unfortunately many key florida precincts
used punch card ballots and a major
issue with punch card ballots was the
fact that on some of them little bits of
paper or Chad's might not have punched
all the way through leading to image
like this and non-stop news coverage
like this Gore's hopes hang by a chair
dimpled Chad's dangling Chad's hanging
chads indented chats
lone chats another claim chad build up a
pregnant Chad the race comes down to the
chats yeah it's true
much like the third elimination in every
season of The Bachelorette it all came
down to the chats Chad G you have the
eyes of a murderer and Chad are your 5/8
Oh Chad R I'm afraid you have to go now
one result of that mess was that America
became understandably nervous about
punch card ballast and in 2002 Congress
passed the help America Vote Act
offering states 3.9 billion dollars to
help administer federal elections and
buy new voting equipment which sounds
great but the venn chair of the election
assistance Commission which distributed
funding for the new machines realized
that there was a problem immediately I
was forced to send 2.3 billion dollars
to the 50 states to buy equipment even
though the equipment was not ready to be
bought so why'd you do it we had to do
it we begged Congress let us do the
research before we send the money and
Congress said no so the politicians knew
these machines wouldn't work the
politicians don't chair Washington
believes that the machines can't be that
bad because after all it produced them
so they won the race how bad can the
Machine be the machine can't be bad
because it produced me that is some
faulty logic right there he's like
saying reverse cowgirl is the best sex
position because it gave us Abraham
Lincoln I mean it absolutely did that's
just a fact
but correlation does not equal causation
and reverse cowgirl does not equal
Abraham Lincoln unless you're one of
these two machines look he brought
the log she brought the cabin that's
just a history fact that I'm not willing
to argue about
so States rushed to buy electronic
voting machines before they were ready
to be bought and there were already some
red flags one machine in Iowa had 300
ballots fed into it and somehow produced
four million votes and to meet the
demand at least one company out sourced
production of the machines and his
reporters later found quality controls
were sometimes close to non-existent
maraming better named Enoch Island a
Pilipinas Tonga guiding and voting
machine v-bar says he worked on
thousands of voting machines shipped to
the United States with what he says was
virtually no testing done on them
originally a fraction of the machines
underwent a so-called vibration test and
what was this quality control test a
shake milling machine yeah that's it
they tested the machine by shaking it
which is weird because the only time you
should ever shake a voting machine is
when you're voting for Jill Stein in
which case that's actually how you do it
you walk in you shake the Machine and
you leave trust me trust me the sheen
will totally record your vote for Jill
Stein just like you and I both want it
to that clip is actually from 2007 but a
shocking number of machines bought back
then are still in use and aging machines
can be a real problem some counties have
found that the glue holding the
touchscreen can degrade meaning that
over the years the screen can slip out
of place and register votes incorrectly
and the danger isn't just machines going
wrong by accidents there's also the
threat of someone gaining control of
them for their own ends because voting
machines are technically computers and
computers of course are hackable and it
can be far easier to control a machine
than you might expect as this hacker
demonstrates on a model currently used
in at least 18 states all they have to
do this bad actor would be to
of this machine by pressing this button
right here when it's off removing the
card reader removing this you don't need
any tools to do this
unplugging this again you don't need any
tools to do this
turning it on all you have to do is pick
this lock here with a ballpoint pen open
this up press the red button and we're
gonna let it boot up here just click
cancel and okay and now I have full I'm
Annessa under two holy
that should have been a lot more
difficult you want hacking into a voting
machine to be at least as difficult as
breaking into Fort Knox which
incidentally is really hard you need to
build a big giant wooden horse yet you
roll it up to the gate and then you wait
for all the guards to say that's a
a plus horse right there let's
put that inside our fort where the gold
lives and then while they're distracted
trying to drag the horse in you sneak in
the back door and you steal the gold it
takes a lot of work but trust me it
makes you value the gold much much more
now hackus hackus find vulnerabilities
in voting machines all the time and
we've not always been great at
responding a finish man named Harry
Hearst II once found one of the most
severe security flaws ever discovered in
a voting system and he alerted the
company who made the machine they
created a patch to fix the vulnerability
which is good unfortunately while they
put the patch out in 2006 we know the
state of Georgia just never installed it
because a recent court case found their
machines had not been updated since at
least 2005 they've essentially been
hitting the remind me tomorrow button on
a critical security update for over a
decade
meaning Georgia's election systems
operate at the same level of technical
proficiency as every dad
his laptop weighs 21 pounds he has a
yahoo mail address that he can't open
because it only receives porn and he has
a hotmail address he can't open because
it only sends porn to his yahoo address
his life is a beautiful mystery and look
voting machine companies and election
officials will tell you that hacks like
that one take place in very controlled
settings and then it would be difficult
to do that in an actual booth without
people noticing but it is not always as
difficult to get some alone time with a
machine as you might think
professor ed Felten of Princeton
performs an exercise every election day
he drives around Princeton to various
polling locations and he follows the
prominent signs that say voting here
days before the election and then he
takes photographs of unattended voting
machines just sitting there and that's
for him to document that anybody can
walk up to these voting machines and
anybody can manipulate them and nobody
will know so to recap
I've now shown you how to hack voting
machines in less than two minutes and
how to find unattended voting machines
it's the kind of important educational
work we do here at I really hope Putin
doesn't watch this show with John Oliver
and to be clear you don't you don't have
to actually have hands-on contact with a
voting machine to Hackett's if it's
connected to the Internet you can get
into it from anywhere although on that
front many election officials insist you
have absolutely nothing to worry about
our machines are not connected to the
Internet and they're not gonna be
connected to the Internet
no state is on the Internet I find it
difficult to hack something that's not
on the Internet
our voting systems are never connected
to the Internet ok
so so first let's deal with this because
I I am aware that that man is a lot he's
his name and this is true is Stan Stan
art and he's he's not in fact exact
Galifianakis character he's he's a real
human and was actually the clerk for the
largest county of Texas until just last
year this was his official photo and
there is nothing I don't like about that
picture besides the fact that it simply
hasn't winked at me yet oh right back at
just stand at the MANET although I will
say this for a guy so sure that his
voting systems are not connected to the
Internet
watch what happens when a reporter asks
a very basic follow-up for the Harris
County voting machines connected to the
internet never says it ever connected to
a modem nope
well the I say that it is a secure modem
where we dial to an old-fashioned
landline to the one of our four drop-off
sites you literally just described the
Internet it's like he said I've never
eaten a banana split only for that
reporter to ask then what are you eating
right now Stan why it's just bananas an
ice cream topped with fudge I call it a
fruity Fantasia but why so some machines
that officials insists don't connect to
the internet actually do connect to the
internet and even some machines that
don't connect directly to the internet
are programmed with cards that have
themselves being programmed on computers
that connect to the internet so your
voting machine isn't connected to the
internet the same way your alexa isn't
recording everything you say and sending
it directly to Jeff Bezos it's totally
not doing that except for when it's
totally sometimes doing that the truth
is every voting machine can be tampered
with in some way or other if I may quote
an extremely upbeat axe murderer pretty
much everything is hackable so so the
solution isn't to make unhackable
machines
that's impossible instead we should be
make
as secure as we possibly can while also
creating systems so that we know for
sure when a problem has occurred which
is an issue because there is good reason
to believe that at least one individual
might try and exploit the
vulnerabilities in our current system is
Russia as Robert Miller alleged
attempting to influence the 2020
elections in the United States I'm going
to tell you a secret yes sure we're
going to do that don't tell anybody
[Applause]
listen to the laughter in that room
Putin is killing and not just in the
normal his political rivals way now the
good news is there is actually a
consensus on what we should do here
specifically that after each election we
do what's called a risk limiting audit
that's where we take a small percentage
of the paper ballots at random and make
sure that they match what the machines
recorded it's pretty simple
unfortunately most places don't
currently do them and some actually
can't because they use the machines that
we that we mentioned earlier where you
vote directly on the machine and there
is no paper trail at all they are called
direct recording electronic voting
machines or dr es and they are very bad
if something goes wrong with one of them
you would basically never know because
you can't audit the results and things
have gone wrong in one local New Jersey
election a husband and wife were both
running for seats on their counties
Democratic Committee the d-r-e machines
said that they lost but they were in the
unusual position of actually knowing
that that was a mistake I knew 33 of the
people that voted for us and we lost 33
to 10 and I knew that that wasn't the
case the results had been switched with
those of their opponents we started
calling people that we thought we knew
voted for us because it was just you
this district of this Township and we
know everybody in this district it's
true that woman literally went around
and got signed affidavits from people
saying that they had voted for her which
means one of two things either the
machine switched the votes or people
will sign anything to avoid a face to
face confrontation hi Cynthia
yes sorry about that election I was
really sad because I totally voted for
you what's that
you want me to affirm that statement
under penalty of perjury well that
definitely sounds better than having
this conversation so fine I'll sign
anything to get you off my porch
Cynthia but the fact is unless you
happen to personally know everyone who
votes for you on a paperless d-r-e
machine there is no way to verify the
results it's a pretty good case against
them which makes it frankly completely
insane that New Jersey not only still
uses them for plans to keep using them
for the 2020 election and it's not just
New Jersey in 2016 20 percent of voters
voted on paperless DRS and an estimated
12 percent will use them in 2020
meaning 16 million Americans spread out
across all these states are said to be
voting on machines that pretty much
everyone agrees are deeply deeply flawed
and if they malfunction there could be
no way of knowing which is absolutely
terrifying because what we have to do
here is obvious it's so obvious in fact
even this guy understands it one of the
things we're learning is it's always
good it's old-fashioned but it's always
good to have a paper backup system of
voting it's called paper not highly
complex computers paper and a lot of
states are doing that yeah he's right
that's it he's just all the way
completely right it is called paper
paper is not a computer it's paper
and a lot of states are doing it now I'm
sure everything he said around those 16
seconds was some combination of wrong
racist and horny but
for a brief glorious moment he was just
absolutely right and probably slightly
horny and look look the good news is
earlier this year the House approved 600
million dollars for States to buy new
machines with the requirement they not
connect to the internet and provide a
paper trail for mandatory audits the bad
news is the Senate has got its own plan
providing less than half that amount of
money with none of those requirements at
all which is simply ridiculous we can
fix this and we must fix this because it
is critically important for people to
have confidence in our voting machines
and we should have more faith in our
system
for choosing our leaders than we do in
the one that inexplicably keeps Sean
Spicer doing the cha-cha on
national television
you